right-wing media figure and founder of
Turning Point USA Charlie Kirk has I
guess you would say been more
transparent on his stance
on gun violence than other right-wingers
are willing to be clarified
what he thinks we should
and more importantly shouldn't it be
more importantly to him should it be
doing when it comes to gun violence
addressing gun violence with common
sense Solutions and as you're about to
watch he thinks the devastation we
experience in this country unique to
this country when comparing us to other
developed Nations is worth it he thinks
it's worth it because of his distorted
view of this whole conversation take a
look now we must also be real we must be
honest with the population
having an armed citizenry comes with a
price
and that that is part of Liberty
driving comes with a price fifty
thousand fifty thousand fifty thousand
people die on the road every year
that's a price you get rid of driving
you'd have 50 000 Less Auto fatalities
but we have decided that the benefit of
driving speed accessibility Mobility
having products Services is worth
the cost of 50 000 people dying on the
road so we need to be very clear that
you're not going to get gun deaths to
zero it will not happen right you can
significantly reduce them through having
more fathers in the home by having more
we'll watch more of this clip but to
respond to what he's already said if you
want to make guns like cars I'm down to
do that that's what I want to do the
same
as extensive if not more process to
license someone make sure that they have
the proper training understanding
um and mental stability to have
a weapon that can do so much damage and
they do this often what cars kill a lot
of people or people a lot of people die
in car wrecks are you saying ban cars no
they're heavily regulated for that
reason we've seen deaths
uh
by car
decrease significantly as we've
increased significantly regulation so
yes let's do it but Charlie Kirk's not
for that
so don't be bringing up cars like that
some point because that's exactly what
people on the side of Common Sense gun
control are calling for implementing
systems to make sure people can't just
willy-nilly get so many guns and
um
people who shouldn't have guns can get
them and all of that
continuing armed guards in front of
schools
[Applause]
we should have a honest and clear
reductionist view of gun violence so at
that point Who's saying we're gonna get
completely rid of gun violence
that's such a straw man uh argument
people think we're we can't so that
means we have to do nothing we can't get
rid of gun violence we have to do
nothing according to Charlie Kirk but
not have a utopian one you will never
live in a society when you have an armed
citizenry and you won't have a single
gun death that is nonsense it's dribble
but I am I I think it's I think it's
worth it
I think it's worth to have a cost of
unfortunately some gun deaths every
single year so that we can have the
Second Amendment to protect our other
god-given rights that is a prudent deal
it is rational
nobody talks like this they live in a
complete alternate universe so then how
do you reduce very simple people say oh
Charlie how do you stop school shootings
I don't know how did we stop shootings
at baseball games
because we have armed guards outside of
baseball games that's why
how do we stop all the shootings at
airports
we have armed guards outside of airports
how do we stop all the shootings at
Banks we have armed guards outside of
banks there was just a shooting at a
bank so
and
people are fully willing to have
Security on the campus of schools now
getting to the point when I hear some
right Wingers talk about their Ideal
school situation where it feels like a
prison is terrifying to go
I'm not on board with that but having an
armed security guard on campus perfectly
fine and also that armed security guard
unless you have an army is not going to
be able to fend off someone
in many cases walking up with a weapon
of War
we saw in Uvalde a team of police
officers countless officers and they
weren't
willing to enter the room as they should
have because of the weapon they were
saying there's an AR-15 there's an AR-15
that the shooter had so yes let's have
security let's have locked doors
let's also not make the environment one
this terrifying to go to and as other
countries do let's
reasonably regulate firearms
how do we stop all the shootings at gun
shows notice there's not a lot of mass
shootings at gun shows there's all these
guns
because everyone's armed
goodness
it's the laughing at the point of
quote worth it that's the words that
Charlie Kirk has for
dead kids worth it because he thinks
that
we need weapons of war because maybe
he'll be able to have some Rambo moment
against the government it's not going to
happen if in some situation very
hypothetically
we were you know experiencing a
tyrannical government where we're going
to have to go to war with them
they if the military is on the side of
that tyrannical government they win it's
over they have the military drones they
have the missiles they have all the
different things we're not gonna
when with even your AR-15 and so to
choose that because you like the idea of
this hypothetical where you're some
action figure
over the lives of children to me is sick
and
he is now out and out saying we've seen
a shift
recently and he's joining along with
that shift within the right wing spaces
the pro
um I shouldn't say even pro gun you can
be pro-gun and also Pro reason and want
to reasonably regulate guns not revoking
your second amendment but just
reasonably regularly guys
um
and we've seen this shift and you kept
thinking or at least I did that
eventually there would be a shift within
the Republican ideology because it would
just get too bad and they would go okay
we need to we need to change our view
and just go ahead and regulate the guns
yes focus on these other areas and the
guns
but we got the shift just not in the
direction I thought we were gonna get it
and now you have a Republican
representative burchett
saying ah you know criminals are going
to be criminals there's nothing we can
do about it talking about Congress
saying
um there's nothing we're going to be
able to do to address gun violence then
Charlie Kirk there
um and countless others just saying yeah
no no we're not even gonna do the whole
we care but we just think
we need to figure out other ways to
address gun violence he's just saying
yeah maybe I'll do a little vague
gesture towards armed guards but we've
seen that and
uh we've seen how as I said a weapon of
War can make that fact irrelevant
and uh so then at the end of the day his
response is yeah it's worth it Charlie
Kerr he's down with it and as I said to
me that's sick and I don't want to hear
one more time
from anyone who holds that position that
they get to demonize lgbtq people in the
name of protecting the kids
or obsess over people
expressing themselves doing drag
performance because they care about the
kids no you don't no you don't not one
single bit if it's worth it to you to
watch them die